le drs et squeeze ça vous a manqué
aujourd'hui on est sur don't take this
risque ne prenait pas souri c'est un jeu
qui traite d'un sujet très sensible qui
est le suicide en gros de recevoir un
appel de quelqu'un qui voulait joindre
la hotline suscite donc un numéro
d'assistance pour les personnes qui
pensent au suicide
il y en a tous les jours c'est
dramatique d'en arriver là peut-être que
certains d'entre vous mêmes sont passés
par là et ce totalement horrible je
trouve que personne ne devrait pas
pousser à bout au point d'avoir envie de
mettre fin à ses jours
sauf que nous nous dans le jeu nous
sommes une fille et on n'est pas du tout
la hotline que la personne voulait
joindre donc on va lui dire bon appel
aux bons numéros va raccrocher est là on
va dire [ __ ] merde
le gars voulaient quand même jaune un
numéro d'assistance suicide il va
peut-être faire une connerie voilà tout
commence de là c'est parti donc mon
téléphone vibre je réponds hello bonjour
non tu es mauvais numéros et noms
restent en ligne laisse moi te donner le
bon numéro et web tu vas pas de but
c'est ok je comprends que très peu de
temps mais non mais c'est pas grave
knight ne pas avoir honte
laisse moi t'aimer paraît non non non
non non on restait parle premiers mois
que tu l'auras demandera de l'aide
je n'ai pas besoin d'être ta magie enfin
on a moins d'une seconde pour répondre
j'ai dit que ça me rendrait tricyle se
blesser mais même ça fait chier
quelqu'un se blesse me suis je connais
pas fait ce nom eh ben je retourne toi
sauf pas à côté de quoi ils pas c'est
tout au plus bas non j'ai pas eu le
temps de répondre mais merde je rappelle
bonjour un sms
il a bu et prendre des pilules non je
vous dis d'aller à l'hôpital
il veut pas mais me dis qu'ils pensent
que les infirmières sont sexy bafa
l'hôpital [ __ ] l'idée qui veut mourir
pourquoi tu veux tuer moi j'ai une
[ __ ] pour j ça j'ai pas le temps de
lire le hockey ahl et dit quelque chose
désolé j'ai eu un blackout fait alors un
bon point est ce qui se passe à bota
maison c'est un bel endroit est ce que
tu dis allez en france ah bah oui il est
en france non un emploi
je peux te dire quels sont les meilleurs
restaurants oppenheim dit qu'il arrive
plus à respirer que je dois l'aider dis
moi où tu es aide moi mes deux motos
adresse
j'arrive pas respirer de m'atteindre s
attend je peux l'appeler j'appelle
n'at il pas espérer pourquoi j'appelle
va pouvoir me parler
hu mais à quel moment j'ai déconné bon
déjà quand j'ai pas le temps de répondre
qu'il a raccroché
donc là il s'est étouffé merde bon ben
ok bon deuxième essai deuxième essai et
là je vais lui dire je vais rester sur
un an tu as pris le mauvais truc c'est
bien sympa qu'il va raccrocher et cette
fois je veux dire ouais je rigole ne
raccroche pas mais je suis trop court je
suis pas pourquoi je fais nous un
canular mais confiance en toi un petit
peu là soit parce que t'as pas le cas de
thibault de chips tu avoir confiance en
toi petit oiseau léger rocker hockey
[ __ ] mais si et non non non mais bien
ce que c'est tout le monde peut tomber
amoureux et faire tomber amoureux
quelqu'un lui je me suis je dit line je
t'aime voilà je lui ai dit je t'aime
j'ai put ok ok pour sauver une vie on va
faire ça comme si désespérée de ouf et
contradictoires il ya deux jours il me
disait que personne ne pourrait jamais
les mais hélas juste je t'aime et part
en vrille
j'ai pas trop le choix ok j'ai très bien
que si je dis non il va se retrouver et
donc non mais carrément budget d'où
personne que tu aimais ok il a bougé
pour développer dans ses bras et amis
contre son truc que je le pousse il
s'enflamme un peu la future 9 mai à new
york cède sa place à ramé sainte voiture
non non il n'y a pas de souci je fais de
toi mais ça va un peu vite alors que de
parler mais non
heureusement que j'ai pas fait sa chacra
tôt ce qui est bien c'est qu'on peut
revenir sur nos choix donc on va voir si
je l'avais pas pousser ce qui serait
passé comme je lui faire un câlin
bateaux non armés d'une couverture d'au
moins tu te qu'il versait franchement je
vais lui dire la vérité je veux dire je
veux juste pas que tu en fait c'est que
luca ce qui se passe quand même je viens
apporter de la deux jours mais là c'est
chaud quand même là c'est plus moi qui a
besoin d'être que lui [ __ ] franche
très vite pourquoi pas parce que tu es
très beau jeu et alors alors est ce que
tu peux faire quelque chose pour moi
promets moi que tu te battrais pour
vivre chaque jour c'est bien ça mais je
veux pas être là [ __ ]
ok on se voit demain steyn pas le
premier soir mon ami je veux pas rester
je passe devant chez toi ô combien tu
connais ça je dis ouais mais je le sens
pas de rester ce soir
soit je lui dis ok mais ne me faire
bizarre mais il va nous tous et la
gueule quand dormira ben vas-y requis on
reste sur l'éditeur à nous faire bizarre
puis s'il est lourd on peut dormir
maintenant deuxième fois sur neuf rester
avec moi pour l'éternité cyclovia d'une
houle ils goûtent et ont des zooms
prisonniers à vie quoi ok on va revenir
en arrière je vais lui dire que je veux
pas rester en position je peux soit dire
ok on reçoit durant soit demain à
l'endroit de matt est ok bon alors à 3
du début ok je lui dis de rester en
ligne j'avais fait le bon numéro
premiers mois de l'année je n'ai pas
besoin des death à londres est restée
bloquée dit la même chose que tout à
l'heure
donc jeudi d'appeler la hotline parce
que ils s'en foutent pas me dis ok
[ __ ] faut qu'ils appellent le couffo
qu'il appelle bon je l'appelle en fait
faut que je m'assure qu'il l'ait bien
appeler la hotline je suis sûr qu'un
happy ending mais c'est dur d'y arriver
ok valoir
ok on est venu il faut surtout pas le
pousser à investir une balle direct ok
on va lui dire d'appeler la suicide
entre line ouais ça pour ça je sais pas
comment tu es d eux ils savent voilà non
je te crois pas tu vas tu es tu as bien
fait de ne pas me croire
il a mis sa bouche contre la tienne
il a fait un gros bisou ok je le frappe
j'ai pas de manquer un peu moqué soit
j'aime à côté de soi je suis prend sa
tête et je lis tous conclut dit j'ai
plutôt faire ça comme ça il a bien mal
et je me bats ce que j'appelle la police
soit je le regarde reprendre ses esprits
non j'ai appelé la police ils trop
dangereux non j'ai pas t'empêcher de sus
des pour te tuer moi même ça n'a pas de
sens soit je l'embrassais soit je
l'exploité contre le mur ok je m'attaque
aux fleurs pour qu'ils s'épanouissent en
mer j'ai frappé trop fort il s'est
énormément il bouge plus soit je sais
que son coût soit pas encourage pas
encore il est mort chez les [ __ ] et
[ __ ] attend on parle d'un mec qui
seconde le numéro je vais pour l'aider
au final je fais un homicide
involontaire c'est moi qui ai c'est moi
qui prends cheikh faye quand même
mordant le au final donc j'ai comme fois
mon objectif au [ __ ] pour les ans j'ai
regardé et il n'y a pas de happy ending
en fait à 9 20 possibles il y en a une
seule où c'est quand tu lui dis pas que
tulle m
oui c'est tout c'est après la vidéo
finalement et les huits oates à partir
du moment où tu lui dis que tu aimes et
que tu vas chez lui c'est là où il ya
huit fins possibles quoi soit en gros tu
deviens sa prisonnière soit taxée de
passer à fond avec lui mais ça s'est un
peu chelou soit eu le pouce et tue le
tue sans faire exprès walid but sous
estime pas dans la tête parce qu'il est
frustré frappe du cou il n'y a pas de
papiers indiquent tout simplement parce
que c'est un [ __ ] de psychopathe c'est
pas juste un mec qui me suicider car
détresse c'est un psychopathe penser que
ces lettres quelqu'un en détresse comme
il y en a partout dans le monde et c est
hyper triste je pensais qu'on allait se
mettre à la place de quelqu'un qui
reçoit un appel vraiment de ces gens là
en détresse qui existent et qui sont pas
les psychopathes et je n'étais pas là
mais la vidéo si l'expérience vous a plu
j'ai trouvé ça très oppressant très
angoissante et entre le [ __ ] j'ai
envie de ledesma klein sa vie c'est un
enfer il est devenu psychopathe
peut-être parce qu'il a vécu des trucs
horribles aussi mais est ce que moi je
suis prêt à me sacrifier pour lui alors
je connais même pas [ __ ] ça c'est ca c
est ce que j comme j'aime beaucoup
jusqu'où surnom capable à aller pour
sauver un inconnu c'est ça finalement la
bonne
du jeu bon tu gagnes pas ça vous a plu
c'est un peu différent ce qu'on fait
d'habitude mais ça fait du bien à
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé surtout mon fils
[Musique]